c'est une femme qui est fière rouge à
lèvres toujours bien coiffé Brigitte
dans Durand crée que sa mère de 94 ans
Solange rien d’eau n'est pas les suivis
médicaux qu'elle devrait normalement
avoir à son CHSLD à sa connaissance sa
mère n'a pas été vue par un médecin
depuis 10 mois est-ce que ces
médicaments qu'elle prennent sont
toujours bon on le sait pas la direction
de l'établissement d'y avoir du mal à
remplacer son médecin parti à la
retraite en avril dernier de nombreuses
familles comme celle de Madame dans
Durand ont d'ailleurs porté plainte au 6
de la montée régie ouest sa frôle
quasiment la maltraitance
organisationnelle et ce qui est pas
tolérable c'est qu'il y ait pas de
couverture médicale
entre entre le délai d'un départ d'un
médecin l'arrivée d'un autre entre-temps
Brigitte dans du rend visite sa mère aux
deux semaines entre autres pour prendre
connaissance de son état de santé allô
un CHSLD privé non conventionné en
montée régie on précise contre les mois
d'avril et doux trois médecins en
rotation aurait assuré les suivis
médicaux de leur 66 patients mais depuis
septembre rien on va aller sortir aussi
la direction
d'embaucher un médecin en faisant du
porte-à-porte le message s'est passé les
approches ont été faits auprès des
médecins il semble pas avoir un grand
intérêt nous de notre côté on a pris
l'auto se promener d'une clinique privée
à l'autre pour recruter en vain aussi
à chaque mois c'est environ 4 à 5
patientes qui se rendent en ambulance à
l'Hôpital du Suroît pour une
consultation ou tout simplement un
renouvellement de prescription ce qui
perturbe grandement certains résidents
qui sont en fin de vie on avait de la
méditation mais ça suffisait pas à la
soulager pour qu'elle ait une fin de vie
paisible donc on a dû la transférer à
l'urgence pour avoir des prescriptions
c'est pourquoi il faut s'attaquer
rapidement à la pénurie de médecins en
centre d'hébergement rappelle la docteur
Ariane Murray à chaque année les corps
se creusent et donc ce que ça fait sur
le terrain mais c'est que on a plus de
patients orphelins
à prendre en charge au niveau de la
première ligne fait que si on trouve un
médecin vous allez en prendre soin je
pense que oui le 6 de la montée rejoued
a finalement confirmé l'arrivée d'un
médecin au plus tard on Mars prochain
bye ici Gabriel prout Radio-Canada
Montréal